bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 week-end alors comme d'habitude dans
ce journal nous allons revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine et vous
présenter les bons plans pour le
week-end dans cette émission également
nous retrouverons la rencontre avec le
groove le groupe mythique elmer food
beat interprète de l'inoubliable daniela
aussi et en exclusivité pour cette
édition l'analyse complète du tableau
saint jérôme de guy doré ni découvert
récemment dans l'église de magny les
hameaux on y revient tout à l'heure
mais pour commencer ce journal nous
partons à versailles rencontrer le young
old timer club dont les présidents
étaient nos invités vendredi dernier
pour ces passionnés d'automobile les
voitures anciennes sont les reines
éternel de la route et une cinquantaine
d'équipages étaient réunis pour la
troisième édition du rallye de la
nocturne anthony rech et jonathan
goodman
jean marc et nicolas ont dévalé les
routes yvelinoise à bord d'une jaguar de
1955 pour ces passionnés ce bijou de
mécanique n'a absolument pas sa place
dans un musée mais bel et bien sur le
macadam on continue à les faire vivre ce
qui est beaucoup plus important parce
que vous avez derrière nous une voiture
qui n'a jamais été restaurée est une
voiture qui a couru dans toute une
partie de sa vie et qui continue à
courir elle sera au mans classic elle a
été au mans classic dans les années
passées setc des voitures qui continuent
à vivre évidemment on s'improvise pas
spécialiste de simca de coccinelles et
autres 4l cette passion se transmet de
génération en génération
ça vient de mon grand père qui avait
bonne collection qui a transmis la
passion à mon père et
fils
depuis que j'ai 15 16 ans gilles
décoller tous les week-ends sur ce
rallye d'une centaine de kilomètres
répartis en deux étapes le chronomètre
n'avait pas d'importance seule comptait
la qualité de la navigation des
équipages c'est l'esprit club c'est voir
se déplacer ensemble à des vitesses à
peu près comparable ce qui fait que les
gens les gens arrivent à suivre et puis
c'est la découverte hier soir on a eu
une épreuve de nuit on a roulé jusqu'à à
peu près mine inondée chose comme ça
et la sauce orienté de nuit c'est assez
compliqué la lampe de poche dans les
dents pour revenir le road book mais
mais ça fait partie du jeu c'est très
sympa toujours aussi sympa l'état n'y
avait de la neige les conditions étaient
moins bonnes mais au moins c'était
s'était dégagée c'était sympa très très
bien à refaire l'arrivée souvent le pire
des moments car la chevauchée s'arrête
il faut alors rangé ses vieilles dames
au garage jusqu'à leur prochaine parade
et il ne manquait que le citroën type h
de louis la brocante
on reste à versailles ou au château le
bassin de latone est en réflexion depuis
quelques mois une nouvelle étape a été
franchie ce lundi avec la dépose de
l'araignée le coeur du système
hydraulique cette pièce majeure de 4
tonnes va être rénovée sur place à la
vue des visiteurs qui pourront ainsi
découvrir les techniques anciennes de
restauration un savoir faire unique
développée par les fontainiers du
château catherine mulato et jonathan
vilma nomme
voici le bassin de latone dans sa
magnificence soixante dix jet d'eau qui
jaillissent à profusion de la gueule
d'animaux ou de la bouche des anges et
voici aujourd'hui le même bassin en
cours de restauration car ils avaient
tendance à s'affaisser toute la
statuaire a déjà été retirée nouvelle
phase avec le déplacement de l'araignée
cette pièce majeure distribuer
l'ensemble de l'eau au jet de la
fontaine fait de plomb et d'état elle a
été réalisée sous louis xiv en 1686
c'était une ellipse donc plusieurs
niveaux de deux sculptures fin de statut
qui elle-même crash de l'eau donc il
faut alimenter chacune de ces de ses
statuts de ses sculptures donc cette
forme elliptique suis celui-là forme du
buffet d'eau
c'est curieux on a l'impression de
retrouver une des sections des artères
et veines c'est après 5 heures on dirait
parce que presque c'est le cas c'est
objectivement le coeur le coeur
fonctionnelle du bassin de latone c'est
lui qui permet c'est ce coeur qui permet
de te faire sortir c'est fluide c'est
tôt ce bassin est remarquable parce que
bien sûr il remonte à l'époque de louis
xiv avec un premier aménagement par le
nôtre et ensuite une transformation par
mansare on également au coeur du parc de
versailles donc c'est le bassin le le
plus central
en quelques minutes la pièce et soulevé
de son écrin de terre pour être déposé
délicatement sur des pièces de bois
c'est là que pendant deux mois à la vue
de tous les fontainiers du château vont
rénover cette couronne de 4 tonnes
depuis sa construction à la jamais été
mise à l'air libre puisqu'elle était
dans la fontaine cacher et elle n'a été
jamais été extraites donc là c'est
vraiment une chance de pouvoir la voir
de près et puis on va s'atteler à toute
cette ces travaux de restauration de
reprise des fissures l'occasion pour les
visiteurs de rencontrer les fontainiers
d'en savoir plus sur des techniques
ancestrales uniquement connu deux les
soudures assure le plomb sont assez
atypiques et y'a que ici globalement
qu'on essaie de d'entretenir pérenniser
ces ce type d'ouvragé les couronnes de
fontainerie qui sont les plans du 17e
avec les soudures à l'ancienne avec les
marque à la fleur de lis tout ce
chantier on est conscient aussi pour
sauvegarder ce patrimoine qui est un
patrimoine que personne ne veut ne vois
pas ce qu'il est caché à l'intérieur
mais était quand même un patrimoine
technique de très grande qualité et qui
témoigne d'un savoir-faire le bassin de
latone devrait retrouver tout son éclat
au mois de septembre prochain pour une
mise en eau avant le début de l'automne
culture maintenant est une découverte
inattendue à l'église saint germain de
paris de magny les hameaux alors qu'en
2012 l'inventaire des biens de la
paroisse est effectuée par le conseil
général un tableau considérée comme une
simple copie et représentant saint
jérôme et mise en restauration à
l'automne dernier le verdict tombe c'est
un original et ils datent du xviie
siècle pendant l'atelier du maître
italien guido reni sa valeur est
inestimable et il est aujourd'hui garder
en sécurité dans la mairie de magny les
hameaux nous avons pu rencontrer
philippe lui est conservateur en chef du
musée port royal des champs il décrypte
l'oeuvre pour nous en exclusivité dans
ce set 8 week-end et le diwan pour les
images c'est une figure d'un saint de
l'église primitive qui choisit de se
retirer au désert ça c'est le terme
consacré
dire qu'ils quittent la ville pour
s'installer en dehors de la ville et
vivre dans une grotte le saint jérôme
donc c'est lui dont il s'agit
est représenté de deux manières soit
dans un bureau c'est un intellectuel
thierry dcri soit dans une grotte en
pleine nature et sur le tableau
l'artiste a choisi un plan très resserré
on le voit à mi-corps il tient le
crucifix à la main donc c'est vraiment
la référence à au travail religieux
du personnage et sa main est appuyée sur
un crâne qui est le symbole de la vanité
donc on est sur une représentation un
petit peu sévère du personnage on a
d'autres tableaux on le voit représenté
en pied et souvent avec un lion à ses
pieds c'est un autre type autre type
d'iconographie au xviie siècle on a un
certain nombre de personnages comme cela
dans la peinture religieuse soit hommes
saint-jérôme soit femmes la madeleine et
dans les deux cas ces deux images que
l'église de l'époque veut donner aux
contemporains leur dire vous voulez
aller au paradis vous voulez faire votre
salut retirez vous au désert retirez
vous de la ville pour réfléchir méditer
c'est un tableau en fait qui est une
incitation à la pénitence et dans sa
main droite il tient une pierre pour se
mortifier il fait pénitence dont il se
il se frappe la poitrine avec avec la
pierre alors la question
de l'origine du tableau pourquoi ce
tableau italiens arrivent ici
donc il faut voir qu'il ya un véritable
marché de l'art au xviie siècle autour
de l'atelier de rennes-ii qui est un
peintre très recherché par un certain
nombre d'églises et stick ou deux
souverains européens
c'est aussi un thème donc ce thème de la
départ vers le désert qui évoque aussi
d'une certaine manière à la présence de
ces hommes qui ont choisi de quitter
paris ou de quitter la cour pour venir
s'installer à port royal donc la
question reste ouverte effectivement
soit ce tableau est arrivé au 19e siècle
parce que riche collectionneur une
famille pouvait la voir chez lui avoir
voulu donner le tableau à l'église pour
faire plaisir aux curés pour faire
plaisir au maire où ça peut très bien
être aussi un tableau offert dès le
xviie siècle en référence à ses autres
ermite qui vivent à quelques kilomètres
de léglise
merci beaucoup philippe us pour cette
analyse on reste à magny les hameaux
mais cette fois à l'estaminet une fois
par mois anne sophie sylard abords de la
philosophie avec des enfants de 7 à 10
ans un rendez vous durant lequel les
jeunes philosophes en herbe s'exprimer
sur des sujets de société sans tabou et
sans parents yoon jung thorez et
jonathan littman ces jeunes philosophes
ont entre 7 et 10 ans un samedi par mois
à l'estaminet de magny les hameaux ils
débattent réfléchissez s'interroge sur
des grands thèmes de société ce mois ci
la grande question était pourquoi on
meurt chacun avait sa petite idée
parce que si on est trop dont on
pourrait plus vif j'aurais pu dire non
parce que le cerveau et marche plus ou
lequel il ne faut plus
et parce que les vieux ou par une
maladie c'est comme si tu étais en train
de jouer et que voilà tu meurt jamais
quoi s'est jamais c'est de la triche je
me souviens qu'on a en ce moment c'est
la deuxième année qu'anne-sophie anime
cet atelier l'objectif est de permettre
aux enfants de s'exprimer sans tabou le
développer leur esprit critique et
d'apprendre à s'écouter malgré leur
innocence leurs propos ne sont pas
dénués de sens leur pertinence et elle
est enfin
elle est vraiment toujours là quoi
je trouve que par rapport à des adultes
les idées sont les mêmes elles sont
juste exprimer différemment
chaque fois il ya un peu de poésie par
exemple le petit garçon qui a parlé du
jeu de l'oie pour résumer un peu ce
qu'était la vie on avance d'une case
chaque jour je trouvais ça c'est joli et
puis après le petit garçon a des petits
garçons qui n'a pas trop participer mais
qui sur la fin quand je lui ai demandé
ce qu'il allait dessiner sur le tableau
pour résumer un peu le débat il a voulu
faire une horloge et je trouvais que
c'était aussi une idée assez pertinente
par rapport à la mort pendant une heure
c'est aussi l'occasion pour ces jeunes
de parler sans la présence des parents
c'est intéressant de discuter entre
enfants aussi parce que c'est différent
de des discussions avec les adultes et
puis aussi c'est pas avec les parents
donc c'est aussi voilà un espace libre
pour eux donc je trouve ça bien qu'il
puisse commencer à réfléchir par eux
mêmes sur leur propre idée bon c'est des
concepts qui sont importants à d'adhérer
au plus tôt dans la vie pour avoir un
petit peu
déjà des axes de pour se construire quoi
tout simplement voilà après ben aussi
avoir un avis autre que les parents
parce qu'on n'a pas la science infuse et
lente ou double
depuis toujours
ok mois
prochains thèmes abordés le 8 mars
prochain les filles et les garçons
et n'oubliez pas que la vérité sort de
la bouche des enfants
le 7 février prochain le scarabée de
trappes peu reçoit le groupe nantais
elmer food beat c'est le grand retour
sur scène pour le trio avec un nouvel
album qui s'intitule les rois du bord de
mer nous avons pris des nouvelles des
papas de daniela nicolas gervais elodie
moines et étienne langues
les piges en fait
il est pour ses manières dans les
stations d'année
je suis le roi du bord de mer
vingt ans parce qu il est tellement bien
qu'il fallait bien vingt ans pour qu'il
mûrisse
voilà un tiens toi ya eu un cap titre il
ya 4 5 ans pour se chauffer on avait
fait un quatre titres avec lévis est
fait pour faire l'amour et tout ça et
des belles chansons et là on a fait un
vrai avec 12 chansons on à fait
différentes choses les uns les eaux dans
différents groupes différents projets
comme on dit par chez par chez nous par
chez vous chez les gens intelligents on
parle de projets et et puis bah on s'est
retrouvé un petit peu par hasard en 2002
veut dire que le zénith de nantes fin
2006 a été un peu il le déclencheur qu'a
dit aulas il se passe un truc quand même
cinq mille personnes quant au moment où
on attaque daniela il se met à chanter
daniela tu dis oh il s'est passé un truc
quand même sur scène on fait plein de
vieux morceaux et plein de ont fait
pratiquement tout l'album plus plein de
vieux morceaux on mélange tout non non
on oublierait au contraire on mélange
tout le neuf le vieux ça qui est bien
sûr celle
dernier de la route technologies on
n'est pas à des
saisies
c'est parti je ferai ce poudre a
construit car je suis un boulot
la rage
on a fait le plein de morceaux et puis
après on a demandé à matthieu ballet de
nous produire dire qu'on a été il nous a
enregistré on a fait les basse batterie
dans un studio et apprendra t chez lui
dans sa maison de la mer et puis on a
enregistré tous le faire à mesure chez
lui que des deux nouvelles chansons et
puis c'était super prime était au bord
de l'eau et à celui qui amène d'idées ça
peut être le lot ça peut être moi ça
peut être que le premier tracé puis
après on va peut être tous ensemble
locales et puis on remet ça
debout tous ensemble
est dur comme fer
je vais le sont
satisfait la une
c'est comme ça qu'on est sur scène en
fait à l'énergie c'est puissant ça
envoie du bois
j'ai d'excellents musiciens surtout qui
joue très très bien le rock'n'roll et
puis moi je suis devant affaires
l'abruti et puis tout va très bien comme
ça je n'ai pas comme un organe
exceptionnel alors pour compenser car
j'ai horreur des chances des chanteurs
qui ont l'air de s'ennuyer sur scène ça
arrive à riches entre bien tout mais je
pense à rien et donc moi pour faut que
je compense et donc je bouge
elmer food beat le 7 février au scarabée
de la verrière la maison de la poésie à
guyancourt a organisé un week-end
d'écriture mené par l'artiste tristan
félix dimanche les participants ont
découvert le mono condyle un style
graphique byzantin du 10ème siècle mais
aussi un style graphique méconnu que
nous utilisons pourtant chaque jour
aurélia debussy et jonathan vilma nom
d'un seul trait voilà la seule consigne
donnée au cours de l'atelier d'écriture
menés par tristan félix sur le thème du
mono qu'on dit une signature enchevêtrés
fait de boucler deux courbes les
participants s'exerce un style graphique
datant de l'époque byzantine
c'est en effet au cours du 10e siècle
qu'apparaît cette forme d'écriture dont
l'objectif est de rendre la signature
inimitable lors d'actes authentiques
pour tristan félix le tracé imaginaire
et improvisées agit comme un révélateur
de l'inconscient une signature dont le
trait continu fait émerger ce que l'on
est
l'identité quelque chose qui me
comment dire qui me passionne qui me
taraude
je me prénomme tristan felix 6
évidemment pas ce que je suis une femme
mon nom c'est un nom de plume un nom
d'artiste
j'ai une vingtaine de pseudonymes aussi
et je pense qu'on est en est une foule
on est tous pluriel mais pour
l'organisation sociale efficiente on
nous a tellement où on nous attribue une
identité et une seule cette idée de
retrouver un fils qui parfois dans la
vie de chacun étaient rompues et il faut
se dire s'amuser au musée a
retrouvé ce film là sans lâcher voilà et
a occupé sur cet espace de la page qui
est un rectangle
occupé le plus grand espace possible en
poursuivant se fit le plus loin possible
dans les recoins inexplorés
parce que dans la vie on est attelé
comme je vous le disais à des métiers à
des fonctions et on explore pas tous les
recoins de ce que l'on a on n'active pas
toutes les personnes que l'on ait la
foule qui qui sourd en nous voilà et
c'est une occasion comme ça de de se
dire
en s'inspirant d'un modèle ancien un
modèle ancestral qui ouvre une voie un
nouveau mode de développement personnel
toutes les stratégies
qui permet d'ouvrir un espace et
d'ouvrir un champ sur ce que l'inattendu
justement et vous êtes toujours des
portes ce qui est intéressant pour
développer se développer au sens large
la maison de la poésie à guyancourt
accueille pour son prochain week-end
écriture les 8 et 9 février la poète
dramaturge claude ber l'atelier sera
dédiée à l'univers des héroïnes
une élection pour élire le plus beau
bébé c'est ce qu'organise depuis 1925 la
marque bébé cadum finaliste cette année
le petit timothée du chéné qui faisait
face aux internautes et un jury de
célébrités à paris patrick jacques de
dixmude pour les images
depuis 1925 bébé cadum élit chaque année
son plus beau tout petit l'élection
remise au goût du jour en 2007 le
désigne désormais parmi quarante mille
bébés inscrire en ligne suite au vote
sur internet 12 bambins sont
sélectionnés pour la finale dont le
petit timothée du chenet qui se
présentait avec ses parents sur la scène
de l'elysée biarritz apparaît en fait
c'est des amis de lucie qui avait déjà
fait ce genre de concours et qui l'ont
mis dans le enfin que lui en donner
envie en tout cas d'y participer et donc
donc voilà on a tenté notre chance et de
puits depuis qu'il a 6 mois en fait tous
les mois on essaye et on a fait j'aime
une chance jusqu'à maintenant et puis on
a eu le top 50 en décembre et top 5 et
puis vv nous allons tourner une fois
donc on a eu énormément de chance
beaucoup de chance peut-être mais il
reste une dernière étape à franchir pour
timothée face à lui les internautes qui
pouvait voter en suivant la cérémonie en
ligne et un jury composé de célébrités
dont la chanteuse préférée était tout
petit j'ai mis comme critère celui qui
était éveillée celui qui était très
indépendant
bon bah j'en avais vu j'en avais mis un
autre mais c'est pas grave cette petite
fille était très très mignonne aussi
qu'on semble bien des cas d'hommes c'est
en effet la petite clara 17 mois qui a
su séduire des votons et remporte ce
concours 2014 avec tout de même six
mille euros offerts emplacement sur un
livret a qu'elle pourra toucher à ses 18
ans ça valait bien une petite fille
excusez-moi chantal goya ça me fait
toujours de l'effet une élection pour
élire le plus on l'a déjà dit jusqu'au 2
février à l'espace decaux villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines expose ses
plus belles pièces c'est une occasion de
découvrir des objets d'hier ou
d'aujourd'hui et de rencontrer des
passionnés patrick jacq de disputes pour
les images toujours
ils sont mollahs beau fils numismate ou
encore les sites zoophiles autrement dit
ils sont collectionneurs d'anciens
moulins à café de pièces de monnaie ou
de flacons de parfum c'est passionné
d'objets d'hier ou d'aujourd'hui
exposent leurs trésors jusqu'au 2
février à l'espace de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux une exposition
multicollections organisée par le club
des collectionneurs des yvelines le club
réunit un certain nombre de passionnés
une cinquantaine qui se réunissent une
fois tous les deux mois et partagent
leurs trouvailles de toute l'année et
essaie de les mettre à la disposition du
public au travers par exemple de
l'exposition d'aujourd'hui
par ici
je suis donc un faux mail qu'au fil
autrement dit quelqu'un qui collectionne
les tire-bouchons j'ai une petite pièce
effectivement du xviiie moitié du xviiie
qui est donc à un tire bouchon à parfum
qui est en argent et qui a et qui a
quand même une certaine valeur on peut
nous pouvons dire donc aujourd'hui et
tire bouchon anglais dont j'ai quelque
chose mais une préférence parce que nous
aurons par exemple des manches en corne
d'autres en ivoire d'autres dans des
bois précieux je considère que pour
l'instant ce sont les maîtres en la
matière si vous dénicher des trésors
dans vos greniers vous pouvez faire
appel aux collectionneurs du club des
yvelines qui peuvent vous aider à les
évaluer
ce 7,8 week-end est presque terminée
avant de se quitter un petit coup d'oeil
sur l'agenda des sorties dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise le
mara catch d'impro par la compagnie
enfance le clown venaient assister à une
soirée d'humour ou en impro des
comédiens s'affrontent sur scène dans un
match de blagues et sous le contrôle
pointilleux d'un arbitre c'est au café
d'à plage à maurepas
globulus vidéo danse la compagnie
ouragane propose un spectacle mêlant un
musiciens et une danseuse il nous
raconte la naissance de la vie et de
l'existence terrestre avec comme langage
privilégier le mouvement et comme appel
à tous nos sens les sons c'est à la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux une exposition d'aquarelles pour
terminer venez découvrir les caprices de
l'eau sur le papier et tout le charme de
cette technique de peinture avec des
aquarellistes expérimentés qui exposent
leurs oeuvres soigneusement sélectionnés
par un jury de professionnels c'est à la
maison des bonheurs de magny les hameaux
voilà c'est tout pour ce 7,8 week-end
retour sur lecture sur l'actualité lundi
avec le 7-8 l'aktu de wilfrid richie et
le 7-8 sport d'anthony rech un excellent
week-end à tous sur tv fil 78 salut